Director Zack Snyder's 4-hour long cut of
Justice League has finally seen the light
of earth's yellow sun.
When Snyder had to step away from the DC Extended
Universe's all star team-up in 2016 after
a tragedy in his family, Warner Bros. enlisted
Avengers writer-director Joss Whedon to finish
the film.
Whedon's version of Justice League was not
well received on release.
It was panned critically and bombed at the
box office.
The reputation of Whedon himself has also
soured among the eyes of many amid accusations
that his Justice League reshoot set was, in
the words of Cyborg actor Ray Fisher, "gross,
abusive, unprofessional, and completely unacceptable."
"Booyah."
Fans rallied for Warner Bros. to "Release
The Snyder Cut" — a once far-fetched wish
that's finally come true on HBO Max.
Most of the main Justice League stars were
quick to come out in favor of the Snyder Cut,
including Jason Momoa , Ben Affleck, Gal Gadot
, and Ray Fisher.
But Henry Cavill , who first played Superman
in Snyder's 2013 film, Man of Steel, had mostly
stayed silent on the subject of the Snyder
Cut — until now.
In a March 18, 2021 Instagram post, Henry
Cavill congratulated Zack Snyder on the fulfilment
of his vision for the DC Extended Universe.
The star wrote,
"Here's to you Zack.
Congratulations!
I know this has been an arduous journey for
you, you kept fighting, though.
I couldn't be happier to see your vision for
Justice League realised.
And what a movie it is!"
Cavill knows a lot about fighting to see something
get made; he was originally cast in a Superman
movie back in 2004 that was set to be directed
by the filmmaker McG , and even got as close
as having a fitting for Superman's iconic
cape.
But when Bryan Singer took over the project
for what ultimately became Superman Returns,
he cast Brandon Routh in the role.
Cavill also used the #HopeNeverDies hashtag,
in reference to his character's slogan in
promotion for the film.
Superman's logo, in some versions of comics
lore, isn't a big S; it's actually the Kryptonian
symbol for hope.
Superman explains the symbol to Lois Lane
in Man of Steel, and further elaborates in
the Whedon cut of Justice League that it takes
its shape from a river.
“The symbol of the house of El means hope;
embodied in that hope is the fundamental belief
in the potential of every person to be a force
for good."
When asked about the Snyder Cut previously,
Henry Cavill has played somewhat coy.
When asked by entertainment reporter Jake
Hamilton why he had remained silent while
the rest of the cast joined the call for the
Snyder Cut, Cavill said he declined to speak
for a decidedly unserious reason.
He said,
"I miss my mustache — which is the most
important thing.
And for me, it was just a harrowing reminder
that I didn't have it anymore.
And so I just didn't want to dig that wound
any deeper."
Cavill grew the 'stache for Mission: Impossible
— Fallout and was legally prevented from
being allowed to shave it off during the Justice
League reshoots.
"Well, I knew you didn't bring me back because
you liked me."
The result, as many know, was that producers
spent millions digitally removing the mustache
from every frame of Superman's screen time.
The final effect flew Supes right into the
uncanny valley for many viewers, so you'd
think Cavill would at least be happy to finally
have his real face in the spotlight in Zack
Snyder's Justice League.
Producers at DC and Warner Bros. are currently
maintaining that the Snyder Cut is not canon
in the DCEU, so Clark Kent's fate hasn't really
changed between now and 2017.
But the critical acclaim being thrown at Zack
Snyder's Justice League may change that.
As columnist Owen Gleiberman wrote in his
review of the film for Variety,
"Zack Snyder's Justice League is the movie
that shows us, at last, what the DCEU could
be ... Now that that's happened, to leave
Snyder by the wayside seems not merely unjust;
it strikes me as foolhardy."
In other words, some critics think that Warner
Bros. should think twice about ignoring the
fanbase to which they just capitulated.
Henry Cavill has expressed interest in returning
to the role.
As he told Men's Health in 2019,
"The cape is in the closet.
It's still mine."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the DC
Extended Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.